im netz häufen sich die
weltuntergangsszenarien zum 23 april der
planet nibiru soll auf der erde
einschlagen
diese theorie stützt sich auf eine
besondere sternenkonstellation an diesem
tag was ist dran was hat es mit dem
planeten libero auf sich und was auf
jeden fall am 23 april 2018 passieren
wird er vater jetzt in clixoom science
fiction herzlich willkommen
es war ein schlimmer tag der 23
september 2017 die welt ging mal wieder
nicht unter es ist einfach zum mäuse
melken immer wenn ein weltuntergang
voraus gesagt wird fällt er aus es ist
einfach deprimierend eigentlich gibt es
kaum ein jahr in dem nicht ein
bestimmtes datum von gewissen leuten mit
spannung erwartet wird weil verschiedene
katastrophenszenarien vorausgesagt
werden im jahr 2017 war es der 23
september
pustekuchen aber und jetzt ist es der 23
april also bleibt uns mal wieder nicht
mehr wirklich viel zeit unser leben so
wie wir es bisher kennen zu genießt man
eine besondere sternenkonstellation soll
heute den weltuntergang ja was soll ich
sagen auslösen verursachen
ja ich fasse sich nicht nur weil
irgendwelche sterne aus unserer
perspektive also der der erde irgendwo
am himmel stehen soll
geht die welt unter nur zum nachdenken
vom mars oder anderen sternensystemen in
unserer nähe aussieht der himmel ganz
anders aus da stehen die sterne woanders
oder es gibt die sternbilder gar nicht
weil sie eben aus einem anderen
blickwinkel auf den himmel gucken es ist
wirklich so eine hanebüchener blöd sind
ja und diese außergewöhnliche
sternenkonstellationen die nur alle 100
jahre passieren soll
ja allerdings im september letzten
jahres da war sie so ähnlich am himmel
zu sehen also die sonne im sternzeichen
der jungfrau soll da stehen genauso wie
der planet jupiter
insgesamt befinden sich am 23 april in
dem cern sternzeichen zwölf sterne was
eben nur einmal alle 100 jahre passieren
soll
ja und warum das auch immer noch mal die
apokalypse auslösen soll
also was wird passieren da muss man die
den das muss man den
verschwörungstheoretikern lassen sie
geben einfach nicht klein bei und
erwarten zum meer wirklich xten mal dass
ein unbekannter planeten namens nibiru
oder planet iks wie sie in oft auch
nennen die erde zerstören wird dieses
mal natürlich kann sicher am 23 april
2018 diese theorie beschreibt
beispielsweise der britische autoren
verschwörungstheoretiker david
ausführliche hat auch diese schlimme
sternenkonstellation für heute verkündet
mit den genannten auswirkungen
also nie büro soll demnach ganz dicht
vorbei fliegen oder einschlagen und wohl
den großteil aller menschen vernichten
einige der verschwörungstheoretiker
gehen davon aus dass die öffentlichkeit
über dieses ereignis bewusst im unklaren
gelassen wird damit sich nur die elite
darauf vorbereiten kann
wie ihr wisst sind ähnliche vorhersagen
weder für 2003 noch für 2012 noch für
2015 oder 2016 oder 2017 eingetreten
ja inhaltlich stützen sich die anhänger
dieser theorie ihrer überzeugung nach
auch die nasa die den mysteriösen planet
negierung vor längerer zeit einmal mit
dem ihrer satelliten beobachtet haben
soll weltuntergangs fanatiker sind
nämlich davon überzeugt dass die nasa
nibiru und es hat 83 entdeckt hat aber
seit dem tod schweigt um eine
massenpanik auf der erde zu vermeiden
jeder wissenschaftliche beitrag indem
irgendwie der begriff plane ticks
vorkommen wird von ihnen als bestätigung
für ihre katastrophen szenarios
angesehen was wirklich dahintersteckt
den begriff planet extreme gibt es ja im
wissenschaftsstandort tatsächlich er
steht aber für einen noch hypothetischen
planeten es gibt ja immer mehr beweise
in den äußeren regionen des
sonnensystemen und na klar
auch die nasa sucht nach noch
unbekannten planeten im äußeren
sonnensystem
doch mit dem wälzer störrischen nibiru
dessen existenz nicht nur nicht bewiesen
ist also es gibt den anfang gar nicht
die nasa würde mir jetzt wohl recht
geben wenn ich absolut entwarnung gebe
es wird nichts passieren ihr könnt euch
entspannt zurücklegen den ganzen tag und
noch alle anderen tage danach genießen
aller wahrscheinlichkeit nach hätten
astronomen solch einen planeten der auf
dem weg in richtung erde wäre schon seit
einiger zeit auf dem schirm eventuell
wäre mittlerweile sogar mit dem bloßen
auge erkennbar
und zum schluss kann ich euch noch
verraten was ganz sicher heute passieren
wird ja nichts jedenfalls nichts
besonderes ja wenn ihr kein thema
verpassen wollen vor allen dingen den
nächsten weltuntergang
dann sollte der meine nummer prozenten
das könnte hier dann erfahrt ihr auch
form von mir vor jedem video also bevor
das online geht kriegt er den link
könnte es vorher anschauen garantiert
und zum begrüßung habe ich bei
ob auch eine ein kleines goodie für euch
und ja auf jeden fall aber auch
natürlich nicht das abo mit der glocke
vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit
meinem video das klingt relativ ähnlich
zum letzten weltuntergang
ja das können wir immer noch zehn jahre
weil die erde eben nicht untergegangen
ist bis dann bleibt dran